do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video in my last video I
talked about one of Circe's closest
allies which is Qyburn but this time I
want to talk about another one of our
allies which is your own Greyjoy this
character has become one of Cersei
Lannister the most valuable assets yet
no one seems to be saying that much
about em now that we are only a couple
weeks away from the first episode I have
been wondering what can we expect to see
from your own Greyjoy during the final
season when fans start talking about how
Game of Thrones will end they usually
talk about the night king or John and
Danny to some extent but what I want to
know is how well you're on Greyjoy
factored into all of this can this
character live long enough to shake
things up will he continue to fight for
Cersei Lannister now you're on Greyjoy
isn't necessarily a main character but
he technically is still the king of the
Iron Islands as of last season Euron has
become one of Circe's most dangerous
weapons so far he has been able to
accomplish each of his missions and
because of this I believe your own now
has some leverage and that could become
very useful the next time he goes to
negotiate with Cersei now the last time
we saw your own Greyjoy was during the
season 7 finale and as most of you
should already know you're on Greyjoy
left that meeting rather quickly he
acted like he was scared of the Night
king's army and since you're on was told
the whites cannot swim he said he was
heading back to the Iron Islands but as
we all know that was not true your on is
actually heading to Essos to get the
golden company for Cersei we even get a
glimpse of this in the season 8 trailer
now we do not see the silence but we do
however see the golden company on their
way to an unknown location I assume they
are on their way to King's Landing in
that scene but you never really know
until things begin to unfold as of right
now you're on Greyjoy has been very
loyal to Cersei Lannister despite his
reputation so far urine has went above
and beyond help Cersei but will this
loyalty last forever
Tycho's which is the man from the iron
bank does not seem to think so he
said as much to Cersei Lysa during one
of their conversations I decapitated the
Dornish snake my Armada owned the Narrow
Sea
Yulin Greyjoy's are moderns there's been
great joy is loyal to me for now
tanana's Targaryen has three full-grown
dragons how well the wooden ships fare
against fire-breathing dragons her
dragons might not be as important as
something that conversation could be
seen as the foreshadowing for a betrayal
coming from your own Greyjoy now if you
take a look at one of the other scenes
from the new trailer it does look like
you're on brings the golden company to
King's Landing I believe that is the
commander of the golden company standing
right in front of the Iron Throne while
you're on Greyjoy is standing just right
off to the side dressed in all black now
I think it's time for us to start to see
your on getting something in return for
all of his efforts now we do have a good
idea of what you're on actually once the
dragon queen
I'm not going to seduce her the iron
fleet will seduce her and together we're
going to take the Seven Kingdoms
I wasn't born to be king I paid the iron
price and here I stand when he showed up
at the Kings mood in season six he did
make his intentions very clear he wanted
to become the king and take the Seven
Kingdoms with Daenerys at his side only
Theon and Yara were able to get there
first
this made Euron have to adjust his plans
because he now has to do it with Cersei
but I believe he still wants to
basically do the same thing ever since I
was a little boy
I wanted to grow up and marry the most
beautiful woman in the world so here I
am with a thousand ships and two good
hands now as of right now there are
still a few things in his way but I
believe he is in a much better position
than before
although the Seven Kingdoms are about to
be under attack from the night king now
the reason why I think Iran has some
leverage is because Cersei now needs him
since Daenerys defeated most of our
Lannister army and the commander of our
Lannister army Jaime has now left to
join the other side like I said before I
think we will see a more desperate and
vulnerable Cersei next season and that
could actually benefit your own Greyjoy
at one time the Lannisters did have a
very big army but their numbers have
started to dwindle after all the battles
they have been through over the years
especially after Daenerys delivered that
devastating blow during the field of
fire not only did Cersei lose most of
our Lannister men but she also lost the
tarly's along with one of the greatest
battle commanders of all time after
taking these losses and losing Jaime
Cersei desperately needs the golden
company and as far as we know urine was
her only means of transportation
now that Jaime Lannister is out of the
way urine will have an easier chance of
seducing Cersei
well after Euron arrives with the golden
company Cersei may finally give him a
taste you've been thinking about that
ginger Minj
wonder why it tastes like if she doesn't
give him anything in return soon that I
could see her finding herself in danger
of losing Euron in his entire fleet now
I know there are some fans who already
believe Cersei will lose the golden
company because of their allegiance to
House Targaryen but I'm not so sure that
will happen now imagine if Cersei did
lose the golden company how could they
make the battle for the iron for an
interesting if Cersei doesn't have any
soldiers to fight for her side Daenerys
could essentially take over the city
before lunch that would not be very
exciting Cersei needs the golden company
otherwise she doesn't stand a chance
so after Euron delivers the golden
company he will be one step closer to
entering some kind of a romantic
relationship with Cersei now I don't
know when they will have sex because as
far as we know Cersei is still pregnant
with Jaime's child but like I said
before when and if Cersei has a
miscarriage I think she will begin to
start having sex what you're on to keep
him even closer than before I actually
would not be surprised if we saw Cersei
and Euron getting married next season
that is until things start to fall apart
in the books Euron's brother actually
has a vision where he sees Euron sitting
on the Iron Throne with who appears to
be Cersei Lannister right by his side
maybe that dream actually comes to
fruition in the show even if only for a
brief period of time but now I want to
talk about something else because I
haven't mentioned this in quite some
time how many of you think there is
still a chance that we could see Dragan
binder for those of you that don't know
Dragan binder is a magical horn that has
the ability to bind dragons to a
person's will now we haven't seen it in
the show but euron greyjoy does have one
in the books during the Kingsmoot during
that scene he has someone else blow the
horn and when he does it ends up killing
him
it turns the man's lungs black and the
tattoo on his chest begins to bleed
urine says he found the dragon binder
during his travels
now that urine is heading to Essos in
the TV show I wonder if he will bring it
back with the golden company that would
certainly make things more interesting
if Cersei and Euron had a weapon that
could take one of Danny's dragons and
turn it against her
since the Narus and John have Cersei and
Euron outnumbered the dragon binder
would almost be like an equalizer it
would level the playing field just a bit
now I know it's a little late in a game
for them to introduce something like
that but it is the last season after all
I think almost anything can happen at
the beginning of the video
I talked about why I believe Iran has
the odds in his favor when it comes to
his relationship with Cersei but now I
want to talk about what I believe will
be Euron's downfall I have always
thought that Euron would eventually get
killed by one of his own family members
in the end I think either Theon will
kill him or possibly even Yara could
kill him
but I think there might even be an
outside chance that Jaime Lannister
could do the deed - we already know
Jaime does not like him and I bet that
Jaime would jump at the chance of
getting to kill Euron Greyjoy
I would only give that an outside chance
though because I think it would be more
fitting if Theon and/or Yara did it now
as we all know Yara is currently being
held captive on your own ship - silence
Euron was able to ambush Theon and Yara
near the beginning of season seven now
although Euron did win that battle I
think he made a big mistake by letting
Theon get away he had the opportunity to
kill both of them during the attack but
he made the mistake of opting out to
play mind games instead this will come
back to haunt him in the end now I know
it might seem very unlikely for Theon to
ever be able to get the upper hand on
his uncle but I believe Theon will be
one of the factors that leads the urines
downfall Yara has been kept alive for
this very reason the show has even been
telegraphing this scenario last season
we saw Jon help Theon come to terms with
his identity crisis Theon has struggled
with this for most of his life but Jon
let him know you don't have to be one or
the other you are a Greyjoy and you are
a stark that conversation gave Theon the
courage to go outside onto the beach and
face his own men he had to go out there
and face some of his fears when Theon
goes out onto the beach and kicks that
man's ass it gives all the other men
just enough confidence in Theon don't
wanna stand behind him that was just
enough to motivate them to want to go
out and find his sister Yara then we see
Fiona walk out to the water and wash off
his face this was almost like fian
getting baptized in the seawater he was
washing off the person that he once was
he was washing off all of his fears and
insecurities now he can stand up again
as a new man with a new purpose what is
dead may never die but rises again
harder and stronger than before
now I completely understand if some of
you think that was corny but this is
what will lead Theon to getting his
sister back and ultimately defeating his
uncle you're on
now if Theon isn't the one who actually
kills you're on that I think
I may be the one to do it after Theon
sets her free we have to see Fiona at
least attempt this because we saw Yara
attempt the same thing when Theon was
held prisoner by Ramsay
the only difference says Yara was not
able to set him free but I think Theon
will succeed where Yara failed we even
hear Theon mentioned this during his
conversation with Jon Snow Gaara tried
to save me this is the only one who
tried to save me
[Music]
he needs me no so why are you still
talking to me so with all that being
said you're on may rise a little bit
further in the story but he will
ultimately die at the hands of his niece
and nephew or at least that's what I
think will happen let me know what you
think is in store for your on Greyjoy
leave your thoughts down below in the
comment section anyways I really
appreciate all of you for taking the
time to watch the video and I also want
to thank those of you who support the
channel on patreon I hope everyone has a
great weekend and I hope to see you all
come back for the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]